[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
consacré à crise énergétique alors que
gazprom suspend ses livraisons de gaz à
l j dès demain jeudi raison invoquée le
non paiement des livraisons du mois de
juillet il avait deux bornes a voulu
rassurer la première ministre affirme
que le groupe français a trouvé d'autres
sources d'approvisionnement
emmanuel macron à va réunir un conseil
de défense vendredi consacrée à
l'approvisionnement en gaz et en
électricité
tous les européens sont à nouveau en
alerte après une interruption des
livraisons via le gazoduc north stream
pour des travaux de maintenance alors au
delà de la france et bien sûr l'ensemble
des pays européens qui vont devoir
apprendre à se passer du gaz de vladimir
poutine mais à quel prix comment vivre
sans gaz russe cet hiver quelle
alternative la sobriété est elle devenue
le maître mot et qu'implique tél
la coupure du gaz de poutine
risque-t-elle de faire exploser à
l'europe on en parle avec mes invités
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
francis perrin bonsoir directeur de
recherche à l'iris et spécialiste des
problématiques énergétiques bienvenue
dans le débat en face de vous guillaume
a case mariant bonsoir député
renaissance président de la commission
des affaires économique bienvenue
également avouent-ils berton signé avec
new bonsoir bonsoir consultant en
affaires européennes et président du
mouvement européen
nous avons également avec nous en duplex
de bruxelles marie toussaint bonsoir à
vous eurodéputés les verts membre de la
soirée mission de l'industrie et de la
recherche et de l'énergie à bienvenue à
vous alors n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez
réagir tout au long de l'émission sur le
hashtag débat france24 débat est 24 plus
exactement on attend bien sûr toutes vos
réactions alors comment se passer du gaz
de vladimir poutine avant d'en débattre
je vous propose un résumé en images de
l'impact en france avec nos confrères de
france télévisions
pourra-t-on éviter des coupures
d'électricité ou de gaz cet hiver le
fournisseur russe gazprom vient de
couper le robinet une situation
inquiétante
la première ministre réclame plus de
sobriété
tout ce qu'on peut faire pour baisser
nos consommations ça nous évitera
d'arriver à des situations où devraient
avoir des coupures on va pas couper le
gaz chez les ménages français mais c'est
sur le nos entreprises du coup les gros
consommateurs qui pourrait y avoir des
coupures et évidemment ça aurait des
conséquences économiques sociales
aujourd'hui les réserves de gaz sont
remplis à plus de 90% mais c'est
seulement deux mois de notre
consommation du gaz qui pourraient
manquer tout comme l'électricité en cas
de pic de consommation il pourrait y
avoir des coupures localisées par
exemple dans une ville de quartier
pourraient se retrouver sans courant
pendant deux heures puis deux autres
zones
autre option baissé de 5% la tension sur
le réseau sans conséquences majeures
pour les foyers si on baisse la tension
sur le réseau peut-être que la lumière
un peu moins intense et clara un peu
moins peut-être que les plaques de
cuisson mettront un peu plus de temps à
chauffer
mais globalement les changements seront
très minime est quasiment imperceptible
un port en particulier vendredi emmanuel
macron organise un conseil de défense
consacré à l'énergie pour préparer les
prochains mois
france espérait y aura-t-il suffisamment
de gaz en france cet hiver
c'est une question à laquelle n'est pas
facile de répondre de façon complètement
affirmative ou complètement d'ailleurs
négative donc ce n'est pas un oui ou non
c'est pas oui ou non c'est le sujet est
plus complexe et donc la réponse est
forcément plus nuancé il faut rappeler
quand même qu'on n'est pas les plus mal
placés au sein de l'union européenne
parce qu'on est moins dépendants du gaz
russe que beaucoup d'autres pays à
commencer par nos voisins allemands et
d'autres voilà on va revenir sur
l'europe après nous avons quatre
terminaux pour importer du gaz naturel
liquéfié
du côté de deux à fos-sur-mer près de
marseille un à montoir de bretagne à 1
dunkerque on va même en ajouter un
cinquième mais pour l'instant on en a
quatre donc ça permet de la flexibilité
aux approvisionnements qu'on a des
stocks de gaz qui ne sont pas suffisants
mais qui sont quand même rempli à 90%
moment nous parlons qu'il se remet à
100% prochainement
que l'on réussit pour l'instant à
trouver du gaz ailleurs que qu'en russie
on est très inquiets on est je ne suis
pas très inquiet mais je ne pourrais pas
vous dire évidemment que il n'y a aucune
chance pour qu'il y ait des coupures
l'idée c'est que on va chercher du gaz
ailleurs on stocke du gaz le maximum
possible on essaie de remplacer le gaz
par d'autres énergies et on essaie
volontairement de baisser notre
consommation de gaz et en faisant tout
ça donc ça fait quatre éléments de cette
stratégie française et européenne on
espère éviter le cinquième le dernier
recours arriver à des coupures et si on
arrivait à des coupures on espère ne pas
avoir à couper les personnes des
particuliers dont tout est fait pour
qu'il n'y ait pas ces coupures mais
l'hiver 2022 2003 qui sera froid ou pas
ou modérées ou un écran dépendra de la
météo combien de gaz russe à ce moment
là qu'est l'état du parc nucléaire edf
au cours de l'hiver voilà quelques-unes
des inconnues majeures qui implique
qu'on ne puisse pas répondre à votre
question guillaume canet ou non oui
c'est ni oui ni non pour vous il y aura
des coupures d'électricité ont peut pas
dire oui ou non en tout cas tout est
fait pour éviter d'en arriver là est ce
que disait effectivement alors à
l'instant francis perrin et comme
monsieur perrin vient de dire tout est
fait pour à la fois sécuriser le
remplissage aujourd'hui de notre stock
pour être sûr qu'on est au maximum de ce
que nous pouvons faire donc 90% c'est ça
c'est comment est même monté le plus
possible on essaye aussi de développer
d'autres sources d'approvisionnement
dont il est question géopolitique
derrière mais la question c'est de
diversifier les hommes le gnl donc le
gaz naturel
c'est-à-dire de dire on fait venir du
gaz venant d'autres d'autres pays on a
sécurisé à travers la loi qu'on a voté
cet été et la possibilité d'avoir un
terminal méthanier au havre temporaire
pour éventuellement sécurisé aussi ces
questions là est bien évidemment au delà
de remplissage des stocks de la capacité
à diversifier il ya la question de la
sobriété on invite très largement les
entreprises d'abord bien sûr ceux qui le
peuvent à la sobriété la sobriété il ya
des coupures par virer moi ça sera des
coupures par quartier on entendait
gagner mais ce que je préfère c'est
interroger les spécialistes sont en
train d'imaginer ces scénarios donc
notre commission des affaires
économiques
va enclencher un cycle d'auditions tout
au long du mois de septembre y compris
avec rte qui est aujourd'hui en train de
faire un certain nombre de scénarios et
qui viendra présenter aux députés l'état
des lieux aujourd'hui de la situation
les scénarios dans les mois qui viennent
y compris les scénarios les plus sombres
charge à nous ensuite de pouvoir faire
la lumière et la transparence sur
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en est là quelles
sont les responsabilités et c est une
sonde ça veut dire coupure scénarios les
plus sombres sait si on a une
multiplication des facteurs négatifs
c'était donc ce black out à la viola si
on peut multiplier fekter parce que je
vais aussi englober la question
électrique mais si on a des centrales
qui sont à l'arrêt et qui continuent à
être à l'arrêt si on a une coupure
totale des approvisionnements en gaz
russe si en plus de ça on a toujours du
retard sur le renouvelable et
éventuellement de mauvaises conditions
météorologiques sur le renouvelable qui
est une interview une énergie
intermittente comme vous le savez et si
en plus de ça on a une météo qui est
très très très défavorable si vous
multipliez tous ces facteurs là et bien
écoutez nécessairement va se retrouve
dans une situation où on produit moins
d'énergie que ce que l'on consomme et
donc dans ces cas là on serait dans une
situation difficile mais on nous avons
besoin avec les experts et spécialistes
avec des personnes qui avec des vrais
scientifiques de faire un état des lieux
de ces scénarios la de ces différents
facteurs pouvoir anticiper et dire la
vérité aux français et les préparer à
tous les scénarios les plus optimistes
mais aussi les plus sombres marie
toussaint toute l'europe est concernée
vous justement qui a représenté l'europe
ce soir est ce qu'il y aura vous pensez
vous des rationnements des black out en
europe on dit peut-être d'ailleurs des
coupures d'électricité en allemagne
est-ce qu'il y en a déjà eu
non non il y en a pas eu mais je crois
si vous le voulez bien que ce qu'il faut
rappeler avant de rentrer dans la
question de où nous en sommes sur le gaz
pour cette année c'est la situation
climatique terrible dans laquelle nous
sommes et en fait on ne peut pas
envisager cette question énergétique et
cette question du gaz sans avoir en tête
le fait que aujourd'hui nous apprenons
que nous avons dépassé toutes les formes
de concentration de gaz à effet de serre
dans l'atmosphère que cette année nous
avons rendu l'eau potable imbuvable
partout autour de la planète et que nous
avons dépassé la sixième neuf limites
planétaires donc le dérèglement
climatique
on en voit les effets et ce qui compte
aujourd'hui c'est de s'assurer que les
européennes et les européens puissent
être approvisionnés en énergie dans les
mois qui viennent mais qu'on se saisisse
de ce moment de crise sur les énergies
fossiles pour changer de modèle et on
rentrait dans une nouvelle ère qui
soient effectivement l'air de la
sobriété et de la sobriété dans la
justice donc pour en revenir à votre
question la question de
l'approvisionnement en gaz et en énergie
en règle générale est évidemment un
sujet d'inquiétude au niveau européen
mais je crois qu'il faut le rappeler
avec force la plus belle des énergies la
meilleure des énergies est la moins
chère d énergie c'est celle qu'on
n'utilise pas et donc on a besoin de
renforcer les efforts vers la réduction
de la consommation d'énergie il ya eu un
accord qui a été signé cet été au mois
de juillet entre les états membres et
avec la commission pour aller vers cette
réduction d'énergie ça a traîné un peu
ça aurait pu être décidé dès février et
je rappelle que 1 % d'énergie consommée
aujourd'hui en europe ces 2 6% de gaz
russe en moins dans notre système est
donc dans la réalité réduire la
consommation d'énergie c'est à la fois
aux oeuvres et pour le climat dans le
long terme et se séparer de cette
dépendance à vladimir poutine et lutter
contre la terrible guerre qu'il mène
aujourd'hui avec rem basse et la
sobriété on va bien sûr il revenir
m'avancer à une question de géopolitique
yves bertoncini d'abord pourquoi les
russes coupe le gaz soudainement à angie
donc ça devrait effectivement être
effectif demain est ce que ça veut dire
là vraiment très clairement que le gaz
reste une arme de guerre pour vladimir
poutine effectivement s'il a pas
beaucoup d'armes vladimir poutine à
l'armé lourde et legs de l'union
soviétique ça marche pas très bien
d'ailleurs son offensive en ukraine et
l'autre arme qu'il a ses larmes
énergétique et s'en sert et gazprom et
un bras armé de ce point de vue là du
pouvoir politique pour affaiblir les
européens les stresser les angoisses et
nous avons un débat sur sur le sujet la
question est de savoir si on parle
d'indépendance de 6 l'interdépendance
qui existe de fait c'est à dire le fait
que nous on a besoin de leur gaz mais
eux les russes ont besoin de nous le
vendre peut aller jusqu'à la rupture la
rupture jusqu'ici lusage en apparence 1
2 arm énergétique par poutine larmes
gazière consiste à déstabiliser les
européens à faire monter le cours du gaz
ce qui compte ce qui permet à la russie
d'engranger des recettes substantielles
est ce que ça faisait partie des
inconnus que vous abordez que vous
évoquez est ce que vraiment la russie
peut aller jusqu'à couper le gaz au
moment de l'union soviétique on avait
une fois confrontation idéologique
sévère et jamais eu de coupure complète
voilà simplement ce qui vient d'être
appelé c'est qu'il ya d'autres inconnues
d'abord l'évolution mais il voudrait le
nerfs il pourrait couper le gaz dans
régnant la team p à tel ou tel pays qui
étaient plus ou moins dépendant on a vu
un don qu'il est l'amant justement sur
l'instru l'assurent il a ça c'est pour
ça que les européens ont déjà décidé
d'abord de se passer du charbon russa
s'est fait du pétrole russe quasiment à
4 plus de 90% en fin d'année et pour le
gaz russe réduction de deux tiers 2/3
mais il finira suppression totale
seulement à l'horizon 2027 parce qu'en
effet il ya une interdépendance qui est
très forte notamment pour des pays comme
comme l'allemagne est donc à ce stade on
pourrait dire que poutine nous tient en
partie en place qu'en 2027 se faisait
ailleurs il ya une diversification t
hawk est en cours ça a déjà été rappelé
et il ya tous les efforts
complémentaires parce qu'il ya aussi un
plan européen c'est en mauvais français
au liban par l'eiu bon la sobriété
l'efficacité énergétique d'une part les
autres sources d'énergie notamment
renouvelables d'autre part et enfin sur
le gaz la diversification ça c'est en
cours mais c'est vrai que c'est un peu
une course contre la montre auxquels les
européens sont comblés d'ici l'hiver
prochain et même le suivant et c'est
vladimir poutine qui en fait à cette
arme dans la main utilisent cette arme
francis perrin on pourrait effectivement
complètement renoncé au gaz russe demain
c'est à dire éviter que vladimir poutine
et puisse user de cet instrument demain
non demain non un moyen terme oui une
2027 oui ou non c'est une question pas
tout de suite à deux calendriers dont
l'énergie il est très rare qu'on puisse
faire des choses d'ici demain ça
n'existe pas et pour le gaz c'est encore
plus compliqué que pour le pétrole comme
vous l'avez rappelé tout à fait
justement à l'horizon de fin 2022 les
européens envisagent de se passer d'eau
d'au moins 90% du pétrole et des
produits pétroliers russes qu'ils
importaient
plus tard qu'au début de l'année 2022
mais le gaz c'est un marché plus rigide
c'est plus compliqué en termes
d'infrastructures de transports
donc ça suppose le pétrole est un marché
plus liquide dans tous les sens du terme
c'est moins difficile de trouver du
pétrole ailleurs qu'en russie que
trouver du gaz ailleurs qu'on si c'est
possible mais c'est plus difficile donc
on joue sur le temps et vladimir poutine
évidemment qui sait quand moi c'est un
crack en profite pour nous envoyer des
signaux pour réduire les exportations
avec deux éléments que vous avez évoqué
un élément économique
réduire les quantités de gaz livré à
l'europe sa affole les marchés ça fait
monter les prix et ce qui l'intéresse
lui en tant que pays exportateurs c'est
pas les volumes qu'ils exportent c'est
pas le prix c'est la valeur une valeur
et en volume multiplie par un prix si le
volume baisse et que le prix augmente ça
peut être bon pour lui et deuxième
élément l'aspect géopolitique faire peur
aux européens vous l'évoquiez aussi dans
l'espoir de nous diviser dans l'espoir
que certains états des milieux
économiques bis finalement est ce qu'il
faut vraiment continuer à soutenir l
ukraine quand on voit les conséquences
pour notre économie est ce qu'il
faudrait pas essayé de se rabibocher
avec vladimir poutine donc ils jouent
sur ces deux tableaux et le défi pour
l'europe c'est de montrer qu'il ne
réussira pas à entamer la solidarité
européenne sur ses deux véritables défis
à relever puisque on sait que viktor
orban le premier ministre hongrois est
déjà allé voir vladimir poutine pour lui
demander d'ailleurs de lui vendre encore
plus de gaz et finalement il a obtenu
gain de cause qu'ont fait les européens
ils ont laissé faire finalement ils
n'ont pas eu le choix bah écoutez moi en
tout cas je pense qu'il faut avoir une
solidarité totale avec un légume
division des lames écouter un moment il
ya des principes il ya des valeurs il ya
un conflit à nos portes il ya un
engagement européen et une unité
européenne qui a été créé à ce moment là
et je pense qu'il faut être constant
dans ses valeurs dans sa philosophie
dans son idéologie aussi et donc moi je
ne change pas de braquet en vous disant
tout d'un coup il faudrait aller
embrasser vladimir poutine parce que
vladimir poutine va vous livrer du gaz
lorsque victor la question c'est la
question
ma question c'est celle de la
souveraineté c'est comment est-ce qu'on
retrouve de la souveraineté et de la
maîtrise nous mêmes de nos valeurs de
notre de notre fonctionnement sans
dépendre d'une puissance et c'est ça je
crois l'enjeu pour l'énergie en général
dans les années qui viennent c'est
comment est ce qu'on arrive à sécuriser
une diversité d approvisionnement qui
fait qu'on ne dépend pas d'une seule
puissance mais qu'on est réparti les
yeux dans plusieurs paniers comment
est-ce qu'on a une technologie je pense
notamment au nucléaire sur lesquels on a
une filière industrielle que l'on
développe sur lequel on construit de
nouveaux opère et qu'ils ne tombent pas
en lambeaux comment est-ce qu'on
accélère sur le renouvelable pour être
certain à court terme de pouvoir nous a
profité beaucoup de questions ces foyers
mais parce que les sujets énergétiques
sont des sujets de long terme et c'est
exactement ce qui s'est dit
il ya aussi tributaire de dizaines
d'années d'errements sur un certain
nombre de sujets qui nous ont fait
prendre beaucoup de retard sur des
questions énergétiques beaucoup
d'hésitations aussi du politique il faut
avoir l'humilité de le reconnaître il ya
eu des
écoutes et la dernière réacteur qui a
été livré dans notre pays sur notre seul
sait si vos deux en 2002 et est donc les
décisions d'investissement parfois ont
duré des années et des années on a eu
parfois des recours administratifs qui
ont été faits et des associations qui
ont été très dogmatique notamment sur la
question du nucléaire qui nous ont
empêchés de déballer leur nez
c'est une décision qui revient mais ce
même ses douze terra sur un total de 420
je ne sais pas juste la question de
fessenheim qui va vous résoudre la
question électrique moi ce qui
m'interroge c'est pourquoi des décisions
de construction de pr2 nucléaire n'ont
pas été décidé plus tôt pourquoi il a
été aussi long de pouvoir arriver au
bout de tous les recours et de toutes
les décisions politiques sur le sujet
pourquoi est-ce que sur des projets de
renouvelables y compris sur des l'éolien
offshore
le premier mandat d' emmanuel macron
dents mais je pense que ce mode
septembre à l'assemblée nationale sera
l'occasion de faire un état des lieux
des responsabilités de tous les
politiques des associations de
l'ensemble des institutions de parfois
certains pros pour faire une sorte
d'inventaire mais je crois que c'est
nécessaire les français attendent de la
transparence de la part du politique et
tout n'a pas été bien fait ces dernières
années sur la question énergétique et
nous payons je crois aujourd'hui un
certain nombre d'erreurs successives qui
ont été réalisés depuis probablement la
fin des années 90 par beaucoup
ce que je vous dis c'est que les
français attendent de nous de la
transparence vous pouvez pas demander
aux français des efforts de sobriété
sans d'ailleurs voir un langage de
vérité avec eux sur la situation
actuelle pourquoi est-ce qu'on en est là
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a autant de
réacteurs à l'arrêt c'est une vraie
question à ma circonscription me pose la
question il ya 32 réacteurs aujourd'hui
à l'arrêt sur 56 donc ça interpelle on a
besoin d'avoir des réponses et une
transparence qui fait par le politique
par les acteurs énergétiques par
l'ensemble des experts et des
scientifiques pour y voir clair et
restituer fidèlement aux français l'état
des lieux de notre souveraineté
énergétique
réjouissons-nous si je puis dire dans
notre constat négatif ça c'est pas dans
les mains de poutine sauf que si si la
production nucléaire en france est tombé
à 25 gigawatts actuellement ce qui est
un baba historique c'est pas de la faute
de la lumière poutine à qui la faute ah
bah il ya eu des défauts nouvelles
élections lorsqu'un ennemi à tarbes à
vous vous allez faire des auditions avec
le saura ce qui est positif c'est que ce
qui est prévu par edf c'est qu'elle
remonte normalement vers 50 50 gigawatts
un peu au dessus d'ici l'hiver donc ça
c'est un élément de l'équation vous avez
exposé qui est dans nos mains de la même
façon que la sobriété et l'efficacité
énergétique c'est dans nos mains moi je
crois pas que la coupure coupure des de
l'électricité ou du gaz des maisons
individuelles soient là l'hypothèse la
plus probable faut pas l'exclure y
aurait peut-être des délestages comme on
dit plutôt vers les entreprises leur
demander de tournée de lorie ferme mais
tout ça c'est dans nos mains au moment
de la crise pandémique on nous a demandé
d'arrêter de bouger complètement qu'on
pourrait pas réduire un peu la vitesse
sur les autoroutes ou sur les autres je
ne dis pas qu'il faut le faire en tout
cas si on veut le faire on le peut c'est
pas vladimir poutine qui va zone
empêcher la diversification le fait de
faire plus de renouvelable comme l'a dit
marie tout ça c'est dans nos mains vous
avez évoqué les décisions les délais
administratifs en france qui sont bien
bien plus long bien plus élevé que la
moyenne européenne c'est à nous de les
les radios conseillers et les volumes
voilà ils ont produit leur sujet
d'ailleurs ne sont pas entièrement dans
les mains de vladimir poutine voilà
c'est ça qu'il faut se dire
réveillons-nous six leviers ce que vous
dites même si coup comme vous l'avez
bien rappeler il faut du temps en
matière énergétique que les
investissements porteront leurs fruits
parfois dans quelques semaines pour ne
pas dire plusieurs plusieurs années
francis perrin ya eu des erreurs de
commises en france dans les choix
énergétiques en allemagne une en a eu
aussi en france l'allemagne s'est reposé
pendant très longtemps sur le gaz russe
avec l'a71
nous sommes inquiets en france mais nos
voisins et partenaires en allemand est
passé au minimum d'après ce qu'on entend
alors clairement
vous vous lui disiez tout à l'heure on a
perdu des compétences en à dire du
nucléaire et on le voit bien et ça
demande des compétences industrielles la
partie nucléaire et la partie non
nucléaire y compris des choses comme des
soudures par exemple donc il ya eu des
mots il ya eu certainement de la part
d'edf des marges de manoeuvre
d'amélioration en termes de calendrier
de maintenance pour qui seront face pas
la maintenance de six réacteurs en même
temps ça certainement à mon avis il ya
des choses qui auraient pu être mieux
fait et puis il ya des compétences
industrielles dans nucléaire qu'on a
perdus par rapport à une génération tel
parti quand vous dites alors va perdre
et à une génération par exemple le
changement la retraite vous avez eu le
départ à la retraite d'ingénieurs de
techniciens qualifiés qui avait
participé au programme nucléaire
français
lancé dans les années 70 après le
premier choc pétrolier 73-74 cette
génération arrive à la retraite on ne
construit plus de réacteurs nucléaires
donc des compétences se perdre et après
quand on veut relancer le nucléaire on
se dit ah mince oui mais on a pas on n'a
pas cette compétence on n'a pas ça on
n'a pas ça on n'a pas ça et ça roule on
a prises ou passe en appuyant sur un
bouton marie toussaint vous est
peut-être réagir justement sur peut-être
ses erreurs commises en matière de choix
énergétiques en france apprend on
reviendra sur la sobriété
oui et puis l'europe parce que c'est
essentiel mais justement je reviens sur
ses erreurs dans l'histoire il faut
savoir qu'il ya 22 ans en l'an 2000 la
commission européenne appelait déjà
l'union européenne à se délivrer à se
séparer à cesser notre dépendance au gaz
russe on en était dépendant à 40% c'est
à dire exactement autant qu'aujourd'hui
22 ans plus tard et que effectivement
rien n'a été fait et donc pourquoi
est-ce que je vous parlais de climat
tout à l'heure pas seulement parce que
je suis écologiste et que je veux
préserver la planète et que je crois
profondément que la justice sociale
dépend de notre capacité à préserver la
planète mais aussi parce que que ce soit
du côté du climat où l'enjeu climatique
appelle à ce que nous sortions des
énergies fossiles que ce soit du côté de
notre indépendance et de la souveraineté
européenne en matière énergétique et
bien nous aurions dû agir depuis
extrêmement longtemps après j'ai envie
de rebondir quand même sur ce qui a été
avancé
j'entends que les énergies renouvelables
sont intermittentes moi je crois que il
est de notoriété publique aujourd'hui
très largement soutenu que les énergies
renouvelables sont les énergies d'avenir
les seules énergies garante de la paix
est par ailleurs capable de fournir une
énergie peu cher et donc c'est dans ce
sens là qu'il faut les aborder
aujourd'hui sur le nucléaire il ya eu
effectivement beaucoup de problèmes ça a
très bien été dit juste à l'instant il
faut aussi tenir compte du fait que la
raréfaction de l'eau va entraîner de
toute manière des problèmes croissants
sur le nucléaire et donc de toute
manière l'industrie nucléaire sera de
plus en plus difficile à soutenir au
delà des dangers qu'elle pose et puis en
matière d'erreurs et là je rejoins sur
la question française vous savez que le
gouvernement français a été condamné
pour une action climatique deux fois
mais c'est pas le seul domaine dans
lequel il n'a pas agi puisque par
exemple si on avait appliqué les
dispositions du grenelle de
l'environnement de 2008 sur la
rénovation des logements eh bien nous
aurions économisé beaucoup beaucoup de
gaz l'équivalent d'une année
l'importation de gaz russe si nous
avions appliqué les législations
existantes en matière d'extension des
panneaux lumineux des enseignes
commerciales la nuit nous aurions
économisé beaucoup beaucoup de gaz et
donc nous serions moins dépendants
aujourd'hui du gaz russe et si nous
cessions est de développer partout des
panneaux publicitaires numériques et
bien nous limiterons aussi une
consommation incroyable et donc c'est
pour ça que l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est
quelles sont les dispositions que nous
pouvons prendre de sobriété pas
nécessairement sur les ménages crois que
l'enjeu c'est vraiment d'aller là où il
ya beaucoup d'énergie qui est gaspillée
consommer gaspiller et donc ça on en
trouve je voulais dit dans la publicité
on en trouve dans le numérique on en
trouve dans la manière l'éclairage on
peut économiser de l'énergie aussi
effectivement en ralentissant sur les
autoroutes en bref il ya énormément de
choses qu'il est possible d'entreprendre
en lien aussi avec l'industrie et avec
l'agro industrie qui sont d'énormes
consommateurs de gaz pour pouvoir
changer changer de système et faire en
sorte que vraiment l'énergie qui est là
et bien soit disponible pour le plus
grand moment leur changer le système
vous dit elisabeth board en tout cas à
demander aux entreprises de réduire de
10% la consommation d'électricité en
moyenne ça fait partie donc de cette
sobriété dont vous parliez on va écouter
bruno le maire
c'est tous les citoyens c'est toutes les
entreprises et toutes les
administrations
nous devons consommer moins d'énergie
chez nous dans les transports dans les
commerces dans les entreprises dans les
administrations
cette un engagement collectif de
réduction de la consommation d'énergie
qui doit être pris et cet engagement
doit être supporté par touches
france espère donc c'est la sobriété ça
devient un peu le maître mot en france
mais pas seulement en france en europe
réduire la consommation d'électricité
jusqu'où alors parce que les % à ce que
ça suffit est ce que c'est bon si cela
s'applique à la consommation énergétique
française et par ailleurs il ya les
dispositions européennes -15% en termes
de consommation gazière doute 2022 à fin
mars 2000 23 donc le gaz est fléché et
puis à l'énergie et les deux
dispositions évidemment sont assez
complémentaires oui c'était un élément
extrêmement important
si on consomme moins de gaz et
d'électricité va moins de gaz maintenant
ça veut dire qu'on en aura plus pour cet
hiver qui sera la période la plus
critique donc il faut avoir en tête
cette dimension deux temps d'abord cette
dimension de court terme comment passer
l'hiver 2022 2023 en france et en europe
avec le moins de dégâts possibles pour
le gaz le gaz on peut le stocker
l'électricité ne se stocke pas donc ça
évidemment c'est plus compliqué à gérer
mais il ya des liens puisque le gaz sert
notamment dans des centrales thermiques
à produire de l'électricité
donc c'est un événement extrêmement
important et puisqu'on a dit sur le
programme nucléaire pour la france vous
l'avez rappelé edf a prévu un plan de
remontée en puissance du nucléaire de
remettre en route à septembre de
réacteurs nucléaires dont plein
planification avec des dattes etc il
faudra voir de très près j'imagine que
vous allez l'évoqué dans les idées dans
les auditions avec les responsables
d'edf dans quelle mesure edf a les
moyens de tenir les engagements qui ont
été pris ce sera un élément crucial pour
la france pour l'hiver 2022 2023 à
guillaume casbah y en a justement
comment mettre en pratique cette
véritablement cette sobriété sans que ça
a un impact sur la croissance sur
l'économie on est restreint de partir
dans la décroissance aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on veut dans la sobriété sobriété
brillante et c'est pas des croissances
je reviens juste sur ce qui vient d'être
dit ce sont des questions absolument
crucial que l'on va poser au président
d'edf puisque nous allons recevoir le 14
septembre savoir est ce que le planning
de maintenance va être tenu dans quelles
conditions et c'est donc nous allons
poser ces questions là et nous devons
faire la lumière sur l'état réel de la
maintenance et la capacité d'edf à tenir
ses engagements
quels engagements sur la sobriété non
l'engagement de repartir l'un sujet
d'offres on a un sujet de production
électrique je vais encore une fois je le
rappelle 32 réacteurs à l'arrêt sur 56
donc il ya une nécessité de faire
repartir le plus vite possible la
production électrique à travers notre
parc nucléaire et donc il ya un sujet de
maintenance et nous voulons nous assurer
auprès d'edf que nous pouvons enfin cac
edf peut tenir ses engagements pour
l'hiver qui arrive je reviens sur
d'autres questions non la la la sobriété
ce n'est pas la décroissance je le dis
la décroissance est une idéologie la
décroissance est une idéologie
volontaire de baisser la production de
baisser le pib de baisser notre
consommation dans une logique qui
viserait à dire que pour réussir à
sauver la planète il faudrait produire
moins consommer moins et et décroître en
termes de pib moi je pense que la
décroissance ça amène de la pauvreté ça
amène une absence de création de
richesses et ça amène des conflits
sociaux puisque vous n'êtes pas en
capacité de redistribuer d'avoir une
politique sociale quand vous êtes
de sobriété qui passe je crois par deux
choses d'une part quand on le peut de
pouvoir économiser l'énergie ça vaut
pour les particuliers mais aussi pour
les entreprises dès qu'on le peut mais
aussi une stratégie d'investissement
pour pouvoir économiser moins d'énergie
faut investir dans des technologies qui
permettent de consommer moins d'énergie
renouveler le parc productif je parle
par exemple pour l'industrie mais ça
prend du temps et c'est rare que ça
apprendre ou qui rend vos affaires
économiques c'est un coup bien
évidemment pour les entreprises mais
aussi pour l'état qui accompagnent ces
investissements productifs pour
économiser l'énergie ça prend du temps
parce qu'on ne crée pas un changement
productif du jour au lendemain vous avez
par des verriers si je prends une
industrie en exemple qui produisent
énormément avec du gaz aujourd'hui parce
que c'est une technologie qui a toujours
été utilisé pour faire du verre passer
du four à gaza du four électrique se
fait pas du jour au lendemain ils sont
contraints aujourd'hui des objectifs on
leur demande quand ils le peuvent
d'accélérer cette transition mais il
faut être conscient que ça va poser de
gros sujet à beaucoup d'industries
notamment même au niveau des ressources
humaines quand on va leur demander de
requalifier de revoir leurs processus de
production de revoir la formation des
équipes ça a un coût financier
ça prend du temps mais ça aussi toute
une logique d'organisation de notre
industrie donc souvent hors de l'écran
du délai pour les contraindre parce
qu'en fait c'est ce qu'a dit que ce
n'était pas l'objectif pourrait être
contraint le logique déjà il faut leur
donner un objectif pour donner un cadre
donné de la visibilité donnée une
ambition c'est ça aussi le fait de
donner un objectif ensuite il faut
accompagner sa ne faut pas les laisser
dans la mouise en leur disant
débrouillez vous et puis faites des
économies d'énergie pour les accompagner
sur les investissements faut les
conseillers faut voir avec eux comment
est-ce qu'on peut lisser la consommation
quand on le peut parce que tout le monde
n'est pas aux trois huit donc il ya
plein de petites choses qui peuvent être
faites au sein de l'industrie qui
permettent d'atteindre ses objectifs
mais faut pas les onze ils n'aiment pas
les atteindre et d'ajouter en tout cas
notre rôle de politique c'est de tout
faire pour réussir à les atteindre et
éviter encore une fois les scénarios les
plus sombres marie tooth à la sobriété
jusqu'où les allemands d'ailleurs
communique beaucoup sur cette question
depuis cet été
oui depuis l'élection du nouveau
gouvernement donc depuis un peu plus
longtemps que ça non mais j'entends que
ça peut prendre du temps etc écoutez 64
% du gaz utilisé aujourd'hui dans
l'industrie européenne pourrait être
remplacé par des pompes à chaleur
64% donc c'est énorme c'est un sac
d'énergie que nous pourrions économiser
relativement facilement mais là aussi on
souffre d'un manque de préparation et
dans la réalité ni les dirigeants
libéraux principalement de l'europe et
de la france ni les grands industriels
n'ont fait les investissements
nécessaires alors même qu'ils savaient
que remplacer ce gaz 64 % du gaz encore
une fois dans l'industrie par des pompes
à chaleur était possible donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à faire ça à faire quoi un à
faire comprendre que la meilleure
énergie est celle qu'on ne consomme pas
2 de réussir à accompagner les
entreprises qui sont en difficulté pour
transformer leurs process de production
mais aussi mais aussi je pense qu'il
faut clairement le dire d'établir des
contraintes pour celles et ceux qui ne
souhaitent pas agir et on peut prendre
plusieurs exemples quel type de contrat
est aujourd'hui accompagné à financière
enfin l'analyse des pénalités
par exemple par exemple aujourd'hui
arcelor est accompagné à hauteur de plus
d'un milliard et demi d'euros par le
gouvernement français pour transformer
ses process et développer des process
moins polluant et moins consommateurs de
gaz en france et donc c'est important
car c'est leur change merci locke c'est
aussi l'une des entreprises les plus
riches du monde et donc dans la réalité
arcelor aurait dû investir depuis bien
longtemps dans la transformation de ses
process de production et donc moi je
veux pas qu'on aille voir les françaises
et les français en leur disant
maintenant c'est la sobriété mais je
veux qu'on aille voir celles et ceux qui
ont les moyens de changer et qui se
refuse encore à le faire et de leur dire
maintenant c'est le dernier moment soit
vous changez soit demain vous serez
effectivement contre 1 je pense que
c'est un enjeu à la fois d'efficacité et
de justice dans ce qu'on essaye de
développer aujourd'hui pour l'europe et
puis si vous me permettez si vous me
permettez à un autre enjeu sur lequel
j'aimerais revenir parce que tout à
l'heure on a div dit mir poutine a envie
que l'europe se fracasse et a signé des
contrats avec lui et c'est une manière
d'affaiblir l'union européenne pour
mieux en porter la guerre en ukraine
mais moi je crois que l'ambition de la
dîmière poutine et de plus long terme
que cela et je pense qu'effectivement
vladimir poutine a envie que la
solidarité entre les états européens se
casse et donc ce qu'on observe
aujourd'hui c'est que la grande bretagne
et la norvège qui sont dans des
situations extrêmement difficiles qui ne
sont pas membres de l'union européenne
et qui coopère avec l'union européenne
10 cet hiver c'est fini on arrête de
partager l'énergie que nous avons parce
qu'on a besoin pour nos propres citoyens
et nos propres et nos propres citoyenne
et bien ça c'est un grand risque qui
pèse aujourd'hui sur l'europe on a
besoin de faire vivre cette solidarité
européenne et l'europe s'est construite
sur le charbon et l'acier kz2
technologie éminemment émettrices de gaz
à effet de serre on a aujourd'hui une
possibilité de reconstruire l'europe
autour d'un pacte qui est celui de la
sobriété juste où on se dise qu'on va
viser la réduction de la consommation
d'énergie ou va viser la vie moins chère
on va viser la protection du climat mais
dans la solidarité et qu'on garde bien
vivante cette solidarité et ce message
là je crois qu'il faut continuer à le
faire passer aux efforts parce que c'est
l'europe finalement qui est en jeu dans
le défi cloud l'europe l'europe est en
jeu un billet vert font signer elle
pourrait exploser justement avec cette
menace russe seront donc on parlait de
viktor orban nkili or demande du gaz
russe effectivement
madame toussaint évoqué la grande
bretagne la norvège qui font pas pareil
voilà qui ont un statut un peu
particulier puisque la grande bretagne
n'est plus une mais plus dans l'europe
mais ce qu'effectivement il ya une sorte
avoir ni va y avoir une sorte de repli
sur soi des différents pays donc des
batailles des mises en concurrence et
puis peut-être effectivement un
délitement de cette solidarité
européenne pour l'instant exclusion
europe ça fait longtemps qu'on dit
qu'elle va se déliter et pas seulement
face à la crise énergétique c'était la
même chose face à ce défi migratoire la
pandémie xterra pour l'instant elle
tient et d'ailleurs elle tient y compris
au niveau des opinions publiques à
l'exception notable du break 6-5 a
poussé les britanniques dehors je crois
que beaucoup le regrette d'ailleurs
désormais donc ses divisions dont parle
vladimir poutine s'est lui dit inquiet
je vous dirai qu'une chose qui
m'inquiète or bams après existait le
double jeu du ctos roban vis-à-vis de
moscou il préexiste simplement c'est un
enjeu de plus sachant que la hongrie
aussi des handicaps spécifiques à ces
pays enclavés difficile pour eux
l'approvisionnement énergétique non ce
qui est inquiétant c'est l'italie parce
que si on italie comme c'est hélas
probable l'extrême droite arrive au
pouvoir là on pourrait retrouver faut
pas nier que matteo salvini même si
c'est plus le leader noria josh duhamel
le ranimer il était très pro poutine
matteo salvini et la l'italie dirigé par
une extrême droite complétant 18 de la
rue si ça ça sera problématique et ça ce
sera un vrai test intérieure mais je
crois pour autant d'italiens sont pas
orphelins ils veulent pas quitter
l'europe déjà sur le rôle extrême droite
italienne avait fait une conversion
spectaculaire elle a bien compris qu'ils
italien ne jouez pas avec l'appartenance
à l'union européenne je crois qu'on
pourra trouver toujours des
accommodements pour maintenir une forme
d'unité européenne parce que poutine ne
veut pas du bien il veut pas non plus le
bien des endroits ni des italiens
vladimir poutine il joue son jeu il a
engagé une guerre aventureuse les
ukrainiens huitièmes têtes de manière
assez assez spectaculaire et courageuse
maintenant nous lé nous nous soutenons
les ukrainiens les américains
soutenaient les ukrainiens alors il est
vrai que nos par rapport aux américains
on a cette vulnérabilité énergétique
bien tous les plans qui ont été engagés
aussi bien au niveau européen ripart
auriez-vous qu'en ce moment au niveau
français normalement doivent nous
permettre de passer l'hiver prochain
parce qu'après c'est effectivement les
populations qui doivent aussi accepter
de telles restrictions 10 % parce qu'on
parle des entreprises mais ça va se
faire nous n'avons qu'avec maison de
prière que vladimir poutine a créé toute
guerre a un coût c'est triste à dire et
donc nous européens d'une manière ou
d'une autre nous en payons le prix déjà
sous forme d'inflation est peut-être je
crois que ça n'arrivera pas en fait je
l'espère sous forme de deux voilà de
rationnement du gaz peut-être pas de
coupure mais de baisse de consommation
mais cette baisse de consommation elle
est nécessaire la sobriété énergétique
et un autre moi c'est l'efficacité
énergétique on a beaucoup parlé des des
passoires thermiques c'est un exemple en
le coup ces mots qui reviennent à la
mode en ce moment parce qu'il ya cette
guerre en ukraine un peu moins d'une
heure et puis surtout consommons mieux
l'énergie l'efficacité énergétique c'est
dans nos mains ça c'est dans nos mains
on va écouter elisabeth borna qui vient
de s'exprimer justement à ce sujet-là
premier ministre française
la première bataille c'est la transition
écologique
nous allons préparer un plan d'action
pour atténuer les effets du dérèglement
climatique et nous y adapter
nous le ferons secteur par secteur
territoire par territoire
c'est le principe même de la
planification écologique dont j'ai
personnellement la charge nous avons
convenu que les équipes gouvernementales
et 25000 cadres de l'état seraient
formés à la transition écologique
c'est à l'issue de cette réunion à
l'elysée toute la journée avec l'omc à
ce variant donc elle reparle
effectivement de cette transition
écologie l'écologie dont qui est au
centre de cette politique énergétique
sauf que sauf que en france pour
l'instant les centrales à charbon sont
rouvertes ou prolonger puisque il ya
celle de saint-avold qui va rouvrir et
puis il ya celle de cordemais qui sera
prolongé donc on va pouvoir se chauffer
mais aux dépens de l'écologie tout et je
pense que et je parle même pas de
l'allemagne qui en a ouvert relancer 10
10 centrales à charbon aujourd'hui dans
la situation énergie éthique dans
laquelle on est la france est clairement
pas la pire dans dans l'union européenne
ou même des centrales à charbon donc là
on est nous avons ouvert la pluie en
mobilité de réouvrir les centrales à
charbon en cas de difficulté y compris
en cas de pic si nous arrivons à des
tensions sur le réseau électrique donc
c'est une solution qui ne fait pas
plaisir ni aux parlementaires ni à
l'exécutif c'est une solution de
sécurité au cas nous serions obligés
pour des raisons de contraintes de
devoir avoir recours à ça mais de la
même manière oui j'aimerais bien c'est
qu'on arrive un jour a quitté le gaz si
vous voulez mais sauf qu'on peut pas le
faire tout de suite vous avez posé la
question tout à l'heure pas du jour au
lendemain si vous voulez quitter la
totalité de ce mois ci les centrales à
charbon on ne va pas dans le sens de
l'écologie donc à moi j'aimerais bien
qu'un chacun fait son acte de contrition
et son dos
examen de conscience j'aimerais bien que
chacun le fasse aussi pendant des années
un certain nombre de mouvements
politiques se sont opposés au
développement du nucléaire nous ont dit
que nous étions dans une situation de
surcapacité de production nucléaire nous
ont dit qu'il fallait en sortir le plus
vite possible et du coup nous met dans
une situation regarder ce qui se passe
en allemagne regarder ce qui se passe
dans d'autres pays ou par dogmatisme on
en vient à réouvrir comme vous l'avez
dit du charbon à être extrêmement
dépendants et à se retrouver dans une
impasse énergétique actuellement le plus
total donc que chacun fasse son examen
écologique de conscience et servi par
les verts le
gilet vert tout à fait je parle aussi de
greenpeace qui s'est opposé de façon
répétée à la construction de centrales
et qui nous ont mis dans une impasse
fuir si aujourd'hui on n'est pas capable
de regarder objectivement la situation
énergétique est de constater que les
combats dit de certains écologistes nous
ont mis dans une impasse énergétique en
europe c'est qu'on l'a visiblement pas
une vision globale de ce qui sera
notre objectif et mon objectif c'est
d'assurer une sécurité
d'approvisionnement pour les français et
de leur dire que tout est fait par
l'état pour faire la lumière sur l'état
de notre parc énergétique et notre
production énergétique mettre en place
toutes les mesures qu'il faut pour
pouvoir répondre à ce besoin est engagé
et accompagner celles et ceux qui le
peuvent pour pouvoir faire des économies
d'énergie c'est ça l'objectif du pôle de
l'objectif du plan etc chacun passe de
l'examen de conscience et j'aimerais
bien qu europe ecologie les verts le
fasse également marais tout ça donc
examen de conscience peut-être de la
part d europe écologie et les verts en
tout cas demandé à part guillaume casbah
rien juste un mot sur ses centrales à
charbon dont cleaner dizaine qui vont
être utilisés en allemagne et en france
aussi on en a on va prolonger
l'utilisation d'une d'entre elles et
rouvrir il me sens sale à charbon c'est
inévitable
non c'est évitable c'est vital c'est
évitable et c'est précisément la
question c'est par où est ce qu'on prend
le bout de la bataille qu'on a amené
alors il y en a certains massugas berlin
fait manifestement partie qui pense
d'abord qu'il faut garantir le fait qu
on est autant d'énergie qui viennent
d'ailleurs qu'avant donc il ya les
centrales à charbon ya effectivement les
centrales nucléaires on a parlé de
diversification d'approvisionnement donc
plutôt que d'aller voir poutine on va
voir le qatar avec dans les antilles
c'est dans la condition politique que
vous savez ou encore l'azerbaïdjan bon
ça c'est un choix et puis il y à celles
et ceux qui veulent véritablement faire
cette transition qui veulent
véritablement aller vers la sobriété et
dans ce cas la première question c'est
de mettre sur la table cette question de
la réduction d'émissions et de
l'efficacité énergétique est très
justement été rappelé précédemment donc
c'est ça l'enjeu est plus on tardera à
agir véritablement plus on tardera à
rénover les logements plus on tardera à
transformer l'industrie plus on gagne
plus on retardera la transformation de
l'agriculture on a un modèle agricole
qui est extrêmement consommateurs
d'énergie et notamment d'énergie fossile
il n'ya plus nous aurons besoin
effectivement de ses centrales à charbon
moi je crois que tout doit être fait
aujourd'hui pour sortir au plus vite de
notre dépendance aux énergies fossiles
et fissiles parce que sur le nucléaire
et la question de l'eau dont j'ai parlé
on dépend énormément de la russie de
poutine également pour notre nucléaire
et puis on vit aussi sous la menace
russe de d'attac sur nos centrales
nucléaires et j'aimerais aussi que ceux
qui défendent une vraie dictature
question là
bien sûr évidemment évidemment et il
faut en sortir aussi vite que possible
mais pas demain on l'a dit je crois tout
au long de cette émission c'est plus
long et plus complexe que ça mais en
tout cas il faut tout miser sur la
réduction d'énergie l'efficacité
énergétique et les énergies
renouvelables c'est un enjeu à la fois
de sûreté actuel de sûreté dès demain du
fait des dérèglements climatiques et des
dangers que posent
l'énergie nucléaire c'est aussi un enjeu
de coûts pour les françaises et les
français enfin bref c'est un enjeu
global oui mais misons sur la sobriété
juste je crois que c'est ça qui doit
être notre français serra un mot
justement sur ce mix énergétique on
pourrait se passer à la fois du charbon
du nucléaire eon pour être continuer à
se chauffer cet hiver non
personnellement je ne pense pas un mot
sur le charbon on a évoqué saint-avold
cordemais c'est dommage mais c'est pas
extrêmement important
c'est très temporaire l'allemagne c'est
plus embêtant mais on sait moins
temporaire parce que c'est senna plus
importants voilà absolument tout à fait
mais il y a ce qui se passe en dehors de
l'europe nous parlons de changement
climatique donc du monde pas de la
france et pas de l'europe nous en
parlons aussi mais nous parlons d'un
problème mondial au niveau mondial la
consommation de charbon en 2022 devrait
être de 8 milliards de tonnes tadié
qu'on devrait atteindre le record
mondial de consommation de charbon qui
remonte à 2013 et on devait les chinois
et que la chine et l'inde principalement
la chine consomme à elle seule 50 % de
toutes charbon consommé dans le monde
l'asie y compris la chine 80 % et en
2023 on devrait probablement battre le
record mondial de consommation de
charbon ça c'est le vrai problème plus
que de rouvrir en france un tas vol pour
six mois mais ça évidemment non pas la
mare de l'armée sur le charbon j'allais
dire à la guerre comme à la guerre on
est obligé de le faire là on évoque des
risques donc on rouvre même en france
mais ça s'est terminé charbon en europe
la construction européenne a été lancée
avec sa communauté européenne du charbon
et de l'acier la sortie du charbon est
programmé inévitable d'ailleurs on a
aussi arrêté vite d'importer du charbon
russe moi je crois qu'au delà de ces
risques à traiter dans le très court
terme faut surtout engager des
changements des changements structurels
et donc le mix énergétique ce site
pratique qu'il montre bien qu'il faut un
peu de tout alors avec des curseurs qui
bouge la france a fait le choix du
nucléaire c'est son choix ce n'est pas
du tout qu'on sensuelle en europe avant
toi et non non par le nom parle
pratiquement jamais mais il yad'autres
il ya d'autres sources d'énergie et je
voudrais par exemple mentionné
l'hydrogène ans n'avait pas encore parlé
identiques quand même cette crise soit
d'une certaine manière une opportunité
d'aller plus vite alors notre gardons un
pays de l'union européenne qui ont
annoncé des paires rivera des pays
riverains de la mer baltique qui veulent
multiplier par sept la capacité de
production d'énergie éolienne en mer
d'ici à 2030 dont il ya l'éolien alors
en france d'ailleurs l'éolien en mer
fait à peu près consensus et l'intérêt
ce qui suscite plus de débats chaque
pays avancera comme il le peut mais
essayons d'utiliser tout ça pour faire
des investissements d'avenir lors en
matière d'énergie nucléaire il ya les
nouvelles générations faut-il encore que
ça marche ça coûte beaucoup d'argent ça
prend beaucoup de temps à court terme il
ya aussi les renouvelables le
l'hydrogène le biométhane voilà il ça
sera une combinaison de tout ça qui fera
qu'on pourra utiliser cette crise les
risques qu'elle suscite ben comme une
opportunité pour transformer nos
économies et puis aussi lutter contre le
changement climatique ça a été rappelé
une opportunité donc ça sera le mot de
la fin merci beaucoup ewerthon signe
d'avoir été avec no mercy francis perrin
merci à vous guillaume casbah riant
merci à vous marier tout ça vous étiez
avec nous en direct de bruxelles merci à
vous tous nous avoir suivis vous restez
avec nous
[Musique]